le tourisme hivernal a transformé la
montagne l'or blanc véritable filon se
renouvelant chaque année entraîne un
courant favorable pour l'économie de
cette région sous la pression des
événements en l'occurrence l'entrée dans
les moeurs des vacances d'hiver et
l'effarante engouement pour le ski les
habitants des vallées montagneuses sont
en possession d'un domaine inépuisable
mais l'affluence sans cesse croissante
nécessite une solide infrastructure
hôtelière pour éviter la saturation à
brève échéance
il faut encourager toutes les
initiatives créer de nouveaux hôtels des
logements des refuges des gîtes de
montagne
qu'est ce qu'un gîte rural monsieur rien
président de l'association vosgienne
d'économie montagnarde nous l'expliquent
un gîte rural est une partie de la ferme
qui est aménagé en logement pour y
accueillir des touristes pendant la
saison des vacances pendant l'hiver au
nouvel an à pâques
quelles conditions faut-il remplir pour
ouvrir un gîte rural bien pour obtenir
un gîte rural
il faut être exploitant agricole ou
artisans agricole ou salariés agricoles
ou retraités de la sécurité sociale
agricole ou encore cotiser à la caisse
des allocations familiales agricoles
moyennant pour obtenir une superficie de
minimum de nectar est ce que les
logements mis à la disposition des
touristes doivent correspondre à
certaines normes
évidemment les logements le gîte rural
doit comprendre une cuisine avec salle
d'eau wc aux sceptiques et des
appartements correct
il est midi fini pour ce matin n'est ce
pas mademoiselle c'est l'heure du
réconfort les skieurs rentrer au bercail
qui à l'hôtel qui office rural il en
existe maintenant un certain nombre dans
les vosges dont neuf à la bresse c'est
une formule qui tend à se développer
pourquoi les utilisateurs eux mêmes vont
nous le dire pourquoi avez vous choisi
cette formule de vacances bien pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce qu'on
voulait changer le cas dans le cadre
habituel et peut aussi parce qu' elle ne
paraissait une formule qui apportait
savons de garanties sur le plan d'eau du
prix des lacunes sur le plan des
conditions
c'est la première fois que vous venez
dans un gîte rural de la première pour
moi m quelles sont vos impressions est
ce que vous êtes sceptiques et à
l'agression d'excellentes oui à la fois
pour lui et de l'installation elle même
et peut aussi de l'accueil que nous
avons reçu de la part des gens sont déjà
extrêmement sympathique qui fait beau
connaître et ça porte aussi le
l'occasion de l'échangé des idées et des
projets madame vous êtes ici avec votre
petite famille vos enfants et tout il
n'y a pas de problème au point de vue
mon for intérieur peut-être un très bon
état la seule j'avais comme les
couchages toute installation est correct
tout à fait je n'ai jamais rencontré de
dégarnir monsieur pourquoi avez vous
fait un gîte rural
il faut vite leurs actes parce que mon
frère en est un mais déjà fait là bas
c'est normal je suis comme il fallait
que ce par la mise en jeu que la place
ne manque pas du g20 est-ce que vous
avez été aidées pour l'aménagement de
surgir oui le génie rural
suivant une subvention boyet dans
certaines conditions naturellement dans
quelles proportions
yvon 35 ans va prendre 5% du montant des
travaux avec un plafond de 500 me sens
si l'action est ce que vous avez de
grosses réparations à faire pour
reprendre gratuitement remet tout
panneau qu'est ce que cela vous vaut à
force de police
une ressource l'action d'environ deux
pour moi rennais une moyenne de 120 à
125 130 et c'est à nouveau le départ
vers les pistes
le seul problème qui puisse exister
étant le transport mais il n'est pas
interdit de faire ce petit voyage est ce
qui vous pend à flanc de coteau histoire
de se mettre en forme après tout les
vacances d'hiver sont faites pour
prendre le bon air
si l'usager y trouve son compte est
cependant le cas du propriétaire de gîte
rural le fisc contrôler ces gîtes parle
d'abord le la taxe sur le chiffre
d'affaires de 8 50% plus le la
rentabilité du gîte qui vient s'ajouter
aux revenus de l'intéressé est également
n'est ce pas s'ils font une demande à la
mairie ils peuvent obtenir l'exonération
de la patente
que pensez vous de l'avenir de cette
formule les gîtes ruraux devraient se
développer à un rythme beaucoup plus
rapide
ils ne l'ont fait jusqu'à lors nous
comptons cette année en 69 environ avoir
80 gîte
il ya simplement trois ans on en
comptait une douzaine
cette formule ne peut être en aucun cas
la panacée attendu par les fermiers
montagne 1 mais elle peut être pour eux
une chance de survie est un moyen de
sauver l'agriculture de montagne